[Musique]
sous ce soleil hivernal
je me n'a pas aujourd'hui comme à chaque
matin des douzaines de pathé jamaïque et
frais du jour pour les clients de son
restaurant coup ma journée commence très
très tôt les pâtissiers de mes premières
choses que je cherche par dix et quinze
douzaine je les mets dans mon réchaud à
la fin de la journée j'en ai plus 400
calme l'atout des parties non je n'ai
pas le sgs2 très populaire le passé j'ai
mis 15 petits chaussons de pâtes farcies
traditionnellement de viande c'est bon
c'est comme un smatch vraiment de sens
j'en vends beaucoup par jour les
parlementaires
le second c'est notre sandwich c'est
comme un sandwich pour moi parce qu'à
l'intérieur on a toute la viande on à du
boeuf soit du poulet soit du lait soit
la chaise mélanger avec une croûte en
croûte de pain comme un coût de base de
farine ses pattes et sont étroitement
liées à l'histoire même de la jamaïque
et de son passé colonialiste
d'ailleurs il ressemble beaucoup au
corner chez des anglais les épices son
influence indienne africaine est
naturellement jamaïcaine avec le piment
habanera chaud vous dans ma culture
jamaïcain on essaie d assaisonnement on
aime salle d épaisses on aime sa voix
des différents goût dans la bouche le
curry ça vient de l'ain mais en jamaïque
il ya un côté indien aussi avec les
épices ego de 32,5 thing et ein volk ein
partout qu'est-ce qui va se vanter de
l'immigration a amené semer un peu
partout dans les grandes villes du monde
jusqu'en fin des produits industrialisés
l'une des plus importantes chaînes se
trouve à new york il y en a aussi à
londres ou encore à toronto
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la ville c'est à vélo
que son livre et ses pattes et
jamaïcains végétalien spécialité qu'à
développer
caroline dans son petit atelier cette
torontoise bibliothécaire de formation
venue vivre au québec pour perfectionner
son français ne trouvait pas de pattes
et jamaïcains végétalien lorsqu'elle a
changé son régime alimentaire
mes parents vient de la grenade mais
j'ai grandi autour des jamaïcains donc
donc c'est ça et puis c'est ça qu'on
mangeait à l'école dans la boîte à lunch
après l'école après l'église de magasins
étaient ouverts on a alors on va acheté
un pâté jamaïcain s'il n'y a rien à
manger à la maison va sortir un package
américain va faire chauffer on va manger
c'est vraiment pratique
elle a développé un pâté à base de
farine d'épeautre et de gras végétal la
farce est composé de protéines de soya
et de chapelure ou de légumes avec cumin
cayenne et curcuma
j'aime le chiffre ise et j'ai mené les
carottes j'aime le lait de noix de coco
et ça m'a manqué le pâté jah mike est
régulier avec avec du boeuf
donc j'ai essayé vraiment de créer
quelque chose qui peut-être sais pas
c'est pas du boeuf mais ça donne le goût
de ce que je mangeais quand j'étais
jeune pour moi c'est important d'en
faire un produit végétalien éco
responsable qui respecte l'environnement
tant qu pas si c'est parce que ça vient
de mes valeurs de la façon dont j'ai été
élevé quand ça sort c'est un peu comme
des flocons de neige
ça sort jamais de la même façon et la
farine d'épeautre est tellement 4
précieuse que ça sent jamais de la même
manière
j'aime bien la route quand c'est
vraiment fléchi c'est vraiment vraiment
bon les cds mémoire incroyable de la
jeunesse ne partez jamais qu'un oui hein
mais tout simple qui selon jermaine
invite à découvrir la gastronomie
jamaïcaine comme on dit les parents
commencent avec un pâté jamais 400 je
découvre quelque chose d'autre je check
et ça me touche le coeur de voir comment
le québec est ouvert d'esprit à doter
d'un différend m de partout dans le
monde
[Musique]